لا كلمات تصف شعور اقاربي ضحايا الزلزال
وهم يترقبون عن بعد حول هذه الكارثه هنا
في شمال فرنسا حيث تعيش هذه العائله
السوريه يخيم الحزن على الجميع بعدما قضى
بعض اقربائهم تحت الانقاض وتشرد اخرون في
العراء
[موسيقى]
بفتح الواتساب احد يعني احد الشباب ناشر
انه فلان اللي هو ابن عمي توفى هو وابنه
ساكنين جنبه يعني فتواصلت مع احد الشباب
اللي بيشتغلوا بالدفاع المدني كان عنده
انترنت
فخبرني انه في اختك وفي زوجة وفي جزء من
اطفالها توفوا وايضا ابن عمي الثاني كمان
بنت توفت لحد الان ما في ما في احصائيه
دقيقه انه كم شخص سواء انا خسرت او اي
انسان حتى موجود بسوريا او موجود بتركيا
لحد الان يعني بالمناطق اللي تضررت الناس
ما انا عارفه شو خسرت
ساعات من ساعات وقوع الزلزال الاولى ترك
عيلته وراح لعند الموقع الحدث بنلاحظ انه
عم بيطلعوا طفل عايش
[موسيقى]